juanito camino de su casa a la parada de
autobús a una velocidad promedio de 5
kilómetros por hora él subió de
inmediato a su autobús y viajó a una
velocidad promedio de 60 kilómetros por
hora hasta que llegó a su escuela la
distancia total de su casa a la escuela
es de 35 kilómetros y todo el viaje duró
una hora y media cuántos kilómetros
camino juanito y cuántos kilómetros
cubrió viajando en el autobús muy bien
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta
vamos a definir algunas variables aquí
los kilómetros que camino estos de aquí
vamos a llamarlos w y los kilómetros que
cubrió viajando en el autobús vamos a
llamarlos ve qué es lo que sabemos aquí
bueno nos dicen que juanito sale de su
casa vamos a dibujarlo para que nos
quede más claro esta es la casa de
juanito y recorre 35 kilómetros para
llegar a su escuela
vamos a indicar que esto es la escuela y
pues va a ser un edificio más grande que
su casa
bien esta es la escuela sabemos que todo
este trayecto es de 35 km
y también sabemos que tardo una y media
horas en recorrer los 1.5 horas
y nos dicen que recorrió diferentes
partes a diferentes velocidades entonces
por ejemplo una distancia la recorrido a
pie digamos que esta es la parada de
autobús entonces esta es la parada
y autobús
autobús y esta es la distancia que él
recorrió caminando es w esta distancia
de aquí es w y toda esta distancia de
aquí acá
qué es lo que sabemos bueno sabemos que
la distancia recorrida
wv más la distancia recorrida b nos va a
dar 35 kilómetros y recordemos que estos
35 kilómetros van de aquí
acá es todo el recorrido de la casa a la
escuela así que sabemos que w + b
más bien
va a ser igual a 35
pero esta ecuación solita no nos es
suficiente para resolver estas
incógnitas
necesitamos otra ecuación y
afortunadamente la tenemos porque aquí
nos están diciendo la duración total del
trayecto es de 1.5 horas vamos a
escribirlo aquí esto es igual a 1.5
horas y cuál es el tiempo que él tarda
caminando vamos a ver vamos a escribirlo
aquí el tiempo
el tiempo caminando
caminando
pues esto va a ser igual a la distancia
que se camino entre la tasa o razón de
la velocidad mientras iba caminando
esto es w km
entre la razón o tasa que es de 5
kilómetros por hora
5 kilómetros por hora
estos kilómetros se cancelan con estos
kilómetros y si tenemos algo dividido
entre 1 / hora pues va a hacer lo mismo
esto que w entre 5 por horas las
unidades son congruentes por lo que el
tiempo que camina es w entre 5 y
siguiendo la misma lógica vamos a
encontrar el tiempo que viajó en autobús
que es la distancia recorrida entre su
velocidad promedio y la velocidad
promedio es de 60 de entre 60 tenemos
dos ecuaciones lineales con dos
incógnitas por lo que podemos encontrar
los valores de w y de b que satisfacen a
ambas ecuaciones a mí para resolver esto
se me ocurre multiplicar esta segunda
ecuación por un -5 aquí me va a quedar
una doble o negativa que se va a
cancelar con esta doble o positiva de
aquí arriba vamos a hacerlo y ahora voy
a poner todo en un mismo color
esta ecuación la puedo poner aquí como w
más b igual a 35 y ahora bueno quedamos
que esta ecuación la vamos a multiplicar
por menos 5 lo hacemos multiplicamos
este lado por menos 5 y multiplicamos
este lado por menos 5 y que nos va a
quedar bueno tenemos menos 5 por w entre
5 estos se cancelan y me queda menos w
menos 5 por b entre 60 nos va a dar
menos de entre 12
y esto va a ser igual a 1.5 x menos 5 va
a ser igual a menos 1.5 x menos 5 es
igual a menos 7.5
muy bien ahora vamos a restar estas
ecuaciones esto de aquí y esto de acá wv
menos w
se cancelan es lo que quería me queda 0
+ b - b entre 12 o b doceavos menos b 2
seamos o un doceavo debe pues nos van a
quedar 11 doceavos de b y ahora de este
lado 35 menos 7.5 nos va a dar un 35
menos 7 nos daría 28 - punto 5 nos va a
dar 27.5 y como aquí estamos con
fracciones vamos a dejar esto también
como fracciones esto va a ser igual a 55
entre 2 así que vamos
así que vamos a quitar esto y escribimos
55 entre 2 y para dejar sola a la vez
vamos a multiplicarlo por el recíproco
de esto y vamos a cambiar colores para
que haya variedad multiplicamos esto por
12 onceavos de este otro lado también
hacemos lo mismo lo multiplicamos por 12
onceavos estos se cancelan que es lo que
quiero y me va a quedar que ve solita va
a ser igual
tenemos aquí 12 en el numerador y 2 en
el denominador pues esto lo puedo
reducir como 6 y 1 tenemos 55 y 11
podemos dividir ambos entre 11 y esto
nos va a dar 5 y 1
5 x 6 es igual a 30
y ve está en kilómetros así que viaja 30
kilómetros en autobús 30 km
es igual a 30 km que es lo que recorre
en autobús y si ya tengo este valor lo
sustituyó aquí pues para ver cuál es el
valor de w si ve es 30 pues entonces w
debe ser igual a 55 30 es igual a 35 así
que aquí
wv es igual a 5 kilómetros juanito
camina 5 kilómetros y después viaja 30
kilómetros en autobús